بالفعل خالد موسم رمضان هذا العام هو موسم
للعمره مختلف كليا عن اخ عشر سنوات ماضيه
وتحديدا الى ما قبل جائحه فيروس كورونا
نتحدث عن اعداد مليونيه تفيد الى الحرم
المكي بشكل يومي وبحسب المصادر نتحدث على
اكثر من مليون و200 الف مؤتمر ومصلي
يدخلون الى الحرم المكي يوميا وساهمت طبعا
منظومه النقل العام في العاصمه المقدسه
بنقلهم الى الحرم المكي بشكل يومي عبر
اسطول يصل الى 3000 حافله نقف الان من وسط
احدى محطات النقل العام هنا في في منشاه
الجمرات هذه المحطه التي تقوم بنقل
المعتمرين والمصلين من والى الحرم المكي
في مده زمنيه لا تتجاوز ال16 دقيقه عبر
مسار ترددي نتحدث في مكه فقط هنالك تسعه
مواقف وهنالك في خمسه مواقف خارجيه وهي
تسمى المواقف الطرفيه على حدود العاصمه
المقدسه تتحدثنا بحسب الاحصائيات انه منذ
اليوم الاول من وحتى الان اكثر من 230 الف
مركبه تم ايقافها في المواقف الطرفيه
واستقلال اصحابها لهذه الحافلات وصولا الى
الحرم المكي منظومه النقل العام اليوم من
المنظومات النقل المهمه التي تسامح في
تساهم في انجاح موسم العمره بشكل كبير
وتخفيف الزحام والتكدسات البشريه
والمروريه والمركبات في المنطقه المركزيه
في الحرم المكي اليوم رحله المعتمر هي
رحله مختلفه فيما يتعلق بعمليه النقل على
سبيل المثال من قادم من ياتي من خارج
العاصمه المقدسه يستطيع الوصول الى خمسه
مواقف طرفيه على سبيل المثال موقف الزايدي
يستطيع من خلاله ركوب الحافله ووصوله الى
الحرم المكي في مده تتجاوز النصف الساعه
ومن ثم يتوجه بعد ذلك عند العوده ايضا الى
مواقف داخليه تقع بالقرب من الحرم المكي
توصله مجددا الى مركبته فيما يتعلق لاهالي
سكان العاصمه المقدسه هنالك تسعه مواقف
داخليه في العاصمه يستطيع من خلالها سكان
ومقيمي واهالي مكه ركوب هذه الحافلات عبر
تسعه مواقف منتشره في العاصمه المقدسه
يستطيع من خلاله ايقاف مركبتي بهذه
المواقف واستقلال الحافله وصولا الى الحرم
المكي نتحدث على منظومه نقل كبيره جدا
تعمل على مدار الساعه نتحدث على ارقام
كبيره سجلتها النقابه العامه للسيارات وهي
الجهه المشرفه على هذه الحافلات وتشغيلها
في موسم العمره كل هذه الحافلات بها
سائقين تم تدريبهم وتاهيلهم وكذلك هنالك
مشرفين من النقابه العامه يعملون عبر غرفه
عمليات مشتركه على مدار اليوم للتاكد من
خدمه وسلامه والتسهيل على المعتمرين كل
هذه الحافلات هي مكيفه بشكل كامل وتحفظ
سلامه المعتمرين وتشهد اقبال كبير على
مدار الساعه وفي اوقات مختلفه تماما اذا
تحدثنا نريد ان ناخذكم في جوله داخل هذه
الحافله نشاهد هنالك غرف مخصصه يتم قطع
التذاكر من خلالها ومن ثم الاتجاه الى هذه
الحافله هنالك رجال الامن يشاركون في
التنظيم وايضا في جوله سريعه قبل ان ننهي
هذا البث كما نشاهد زميلنا يمكن عصام
يعطينا الصوره لهذه الحافلات التي تعتبر
مجهزه بالكامل ومدربه السائقين على
قيادتها بشكل كبير وهي مكيفه طبعا